These young people say
Jordan Peterson should not be allowed to speak on their
on their campus.
Peterson's a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto.
When Canada proposed a law declaring it illegal
not to call someone by their preferred pronoun,
in other words illegal not to
address those who don't want to be called he or she
as say,
Ze or Zim.
Peterson said
he would not obey that law.
It's not just students who object.
Hundreds of his colleagues signed a petition
demanding that Peterson be fired.
They say his behavior is a danger.
Now, when he tries to speak,
protestors often surround him blowing air horns or
screaming
to make sure others cannot hear him.
At this school, he and students who wanted to
hear him moved outside to escape the noise
but the protesters just followed him
and drowned him out again.
If somebody wants to be called Ze or Zir, why not?
I don't care what people want to be called,
that's fine but that doesn't mean
I should be compelled by law
to call them that.
The government has absolutely no business whatsoever
ever governing the content of your voluntary speech.
But if I personally said, I'd like you to
call me Ze or Zen?
We could have a conversation about that.
Just like I would if you asked me to use a nickname
for example so but there's a big
difference between
privately negotiated modes of address
and legislatively
demanded compelled speech.
Protesters call Peterson all sorts of names.
They've called me lots of things.
Hitler that was one.
The fact that it has to do with transgender people
is virtually irrelevant,
the issue is compelled speech.
Peterson handles the protesters well.
And you look pretty calm while they're
screaming at you.
Yeah well, you know better to be calm.
Best to let the unreasonable opposition speak
because they manifest themselves as unreasonable
and then everyone can see it.
You can also see it in this video, viewed
millions of times
maybe because Peterson stays calm
while the TV host keeps twisting his words.
You're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top companies?
No, I didn't say that at all.
He simply says
that natural differences
explain most of the gender wage gap.
Do you believe in equal pay?
Well I made the argument there so I could,
depends on who defines it.
So you don't believe in equal pay?
No, I'm not saying that at all.
Like many on the left,
she insists that difference
proves discrimination.
If it weren't for our sexist society,
we'd be much more alike.
That's actually not the case.
The science on that is absolutely clear.
They've studied tens of thousands of people
in dozens of countries and the papers
have been cited thousands of times.
For years, many leftists denied
there were any differences.
Aren't women in general better nurturers?
No.
Next question.
Feminist icon Gloria Steinem
even objected to researching differences.
It's really the remnant of anti-American crazy thinking
to do this kind of research.
But more research has been done
and it shows that on average,
men and women excel at different things.
That runs contrary to well, contrary to the
desires of the research used to generate the data
because no one wanted that.
It came as a shock to everyone
but that's how it is.
And yet when you say this,
it infuriates some people.
It should infuriate them
because I'm going right
after the heart of the radical leftist doctrine.
The heart of that doctrine
is that all groups should have equal outcomes.
There should be just as many female CEO's
scientists, computer programmers,
because men and women are the same.
If outcomes differ, it must be sexism.
Or as actress Ashley Judd puts it,
"the problem is the patriarchy".
The patriarchy.
Professors teach exactly that.
The United States is a patriarchal society.
First of all, I think the idea
that like men tyrannically dominated everything is a
pretty damn weak argument.
The year 2000 to the year 2012
the rate of absolute poverty
in the world fell by 50 percent.
It's like, that's pretty good for a
patriarchal tyranny.
That was the fastest economic development
in the history of the world.
But on campus the message is inequality,
oppression.
Students major now
in social justice.
Disciplines like women's and ethnic studies,
which are corrupt right to the core.
I pledge to use they and them
when I do not know someone's pronouns.
They're out to produce radical leftist activists
by their own admission.
All you have to do is go to
the websites of these disciplines
and look at how they advertise.
Social justice is different
from justice.
Social justice generally means justice
for groups of people.
It assumes every group,
men, women, blacks, whites,
should have the same income, job preference,
everything.
Peterson says this is an idea
that comes from Marxist professors.
It's a little discredited now to say "I'm a Marxist".
Yeah you'd think so wouldn't you? Except
I think it's one in five social scientists
identify as Marxist so yeah
it's a little discredited
but it's nowhere near discredited enough.
It should be as discreditable to say that you're a Marxist
as it is to say that
you're a Nazi.
It isn't.
On campus, socialism is cherished, says Peterson
although it's murderous.
We've got a hundred million corpses
stacked up to demonstrate.
Murderous then, but they say those Stalin
is a bad individual,
doesn't mean...
Yeah so was Mao, so was Pol Pot.
The thing is,
it was tried everywhere
and the end consequence was always the same.
I've heard this all many, many times.
That wasn't real communism.
You know what that means?
That means that if I would have been
the benevolent dictator in the place of
Stalin, then I would have brought in the utopia.
There isn't a more narcissistic and toxic
and inexcusable statement that you can possibly make.
We actually value the individual.
Peterson offers an alternative
and videos that suddenly are being viewed by millions.
The individual has intrinsic value.
Peterson calls for the opposite of Marxism,
individual sovereignty.
The free-market principles, the idea of
individual sovereignty above all else
is distributed itself across the world quite effectively
and everyone is doing better here
than anybody has ever done
on the face of the planet
throughout recorded history and the whole West is
like that
and to call that all a tyrannical patriarchy
is indicative of a very deep resentment
and a historical ignorance that's so profound that it's
indistinguishable from willful blindness.
Peterson says the best thing people can do
to fight back against that blindness
is to speak the truth, even when it's unpopular.
Peterson follows his own advice.
He says unpopular truths and
people like that.
Almost a million have bought his book.